toutes ces dessins la première fois
qu'ils sont comme toutes les mamans
josiane stratis est fier de son fils
arthur elle est tombée enceinte il y a 6
ans quelques mois à peine après avoir
subi un avortement à redon qui a écrit
papa d'amour c'est nous comme un gros
gros tigre et quand ça arrive dans un
moment de la vie où tombait pas d'enfant
de choeur
cette incertitude qui peut aller plus
loin que j'entends sécurité à toi tu es
comme c'est pas vrai que j'en vois bien
en formule 1 depuis que l'alabama a
adopté une des lois les plus
restrictives sur l'avortement
des milliers de femmes ont choisi de
sortir de l'ombre pour en finir avec la
honte de leurs avortements en utilisant
le hashtag yunomi j'avais 30 ans déjà
deux enfants
j'étais mari mais surtout un style est
l'instigatrice derrière ce mouvement
c'est cette animatrice américaine
une femme sur quatre a recours à un
avortement avant l'âge de 45 ans si vous
croyez ne connaître aucune
eh bien vous me connaissez moi at elle
déclaré sur les ondes depuis c'est une
véritable déferlante sur les médias
sociaux
un élan de solidarité qui rappelle
beaucoup celui de mitu concernant les
violences sexuelles
c'est le même principe c'est de
renverser
la charge la honte ce n'est pas à nous
de la voie en dépit d une grossesse non
planifiée le ça se fait à deux mais
peut-on s'attendre à une montée des
mouvements anti avortement de ce côté ci
de la frontière
l'avortement au canada elle est
décriminalisée aux etats unis c'est
légaliser donc quand même une différence
ce qui fait en sorte qu'aucun la donne
pourrait pas morceler le droit parce
qu'il n'ya pas de loi qui légalise
l'avortement
par contre les liens entre les groupes
pro-vie américains et canadiens sont
indéniables ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux et leur agenda politique est
claire un début de campagne québec vie
c'est sa voix une présence sur l'arène
politique le mouvement anti choix est
considéré par la droite conservatrice de
manière un peu plus générales comme
étant un mouvement qui réussit en ce
moment et qui et parvient à faire
avancer son agenda idéologique
même si plusieurs politiciens canadiens
ouvertement contre l'avortement affirme
n'avoir aucune intention de rouvrir ce
débat au pays leur position pourrait
galvaniser les troupes pro vie c'est
légitime l'opposition à l'avortement et
ça laisse place justement à des discours
plus stéréotypé sur l'avortement et à la
désinformation
donc c'est là le danger et le glissement
qui pourrait se faire
un glissement que redoute certaines
femmes comme josiane les droits des
femmes est toujours chambre à issigeac
ou de richard beaudoux raid au canada
montréal